depuis le 12 juillet dernier et les
annonces des manuels macron sur le pass
sanitaires l'exécutif n'a pas bougé d'un
iota dans son jusqu'au boutisme
vaccinale est désormais si vous avez
exercer votre droit ne pas vous faire
vacciner contre le coc u19 votre vie va
devenir encore plus dur comme promis
comme annoncé par le président de la
république le 12 juillet dernier la fin
de la gratuité générale des tests de
dépistage du coc vite 19 sera mise en
oeuvre le 15 octobre 2021 le
gouvernement continue ainsi à encourager
la vaccination qui constitue la
meilleure façon de se protéger et de
protéger les autres est la clef de la
sortie durable de crise fini donc les
tests dits de confort qui permettait à
ceux qui refusent le vaccin d'avoir une
vie à peu près normale entre deux tests
naso pharyngé remboursés par la sécurité
sociale désormais il faudra payer et les
tarifs sont dissuasifs environ 22 à 45
euros en france métropolitaine en
fonction du moyen utilisé n'espérait pas
non plus vous en tirez avec un autotest
qui coûte environ 5 euros ils ne
permettent plus d'obtenir le qr code qui
ouvre toutes les portes il y a quand
même des exceptions détaillé par le
ministère de la santé notamment pour les
mineurs ou les personnes vaccinées les
autres devront avoir une prescription
médicale pour bénéficier d'un test
rembourser ils ont réussi leurs
objectifs mais encore une fois on voit
bien que voilà l'objectif du passage
terre c'est pas un objectif sanitaire
c'est un objectif politique l'objectif
politique c'est quoi cette vacciner tout
le monde même si on voit de plus en plus
dans les études notamment américaines
que la vaccination ne protège pas aussi
bien contre la transmissibilité du virus
donc c'est toujours la même chose donc
oui le gouvernement a gagné son pari si
vous voulez mais ce qui serait bien
c'est pas que le gouvernement gagne
c'est que la raison triomphe un peu
comme maintenant qu'on accepte le
principe du pass yali taire et accepter
de vivre comme une société de contrôle
on vous a restreint l'accès au bar et au
restaurant
qu'est-ce qui peut demain empêcher je ne
sais pas moi les banques de vous refuser
une ouverture de compte si vous n'êtes
pas vacciné
qu'est-ce qui peut rhdp qu'est ce qui
peut empêcher demain qu'on étende à à
d'autres secteurs
je moi je pense qu'on n'a pas fini d'en
voir le bout et c'est vrai que c'est
très inquiétant parce que les gens se
sont accoutumés à ça ils se sont
accoutumés à montrer un qrcode très
naturellement très simplement mais ils
ne comprennent pas de basculement
anthropologique philosophique et
politique dans lequel nous sommes depuis
quelques mois maintenant selon le
ministère de la santé la vaccination est
le seul moyen de sortir de la crise et
il reste 7,5 millions de personnes
éligibles à vacciner tous les moyens
sont bons pour aller les chercher y
compris les plus contraignants certains
dans la classe politique veulent aller
plus loin le 13 octobre les sénateurs
débattront d'une proposition de loi
socialiste visant à ajouter le coc vite
19 au vaccin obligatoire une proposition
de loi qui a cependant peu de chances
d'aboutir puisque la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat a d'ores et
déjà rejeté le texte ce qui laisse
penser que la majorité n'est pas
favorable à la mesure du moins pour
l'instant